what's going on it's travis thompson and
you can check me out on the bootleg kev
podcast
yo man bootleg cab show special guest in
here the boulevard boy himself what's
good it's your boy travis thompson thank
you man thank you for having me brad
holy [ __ ] it's been a while man good to
see you good to see you i haven't seen
you since
all this pandemic [ __ ] been popping it's
been a [ __ ] grip bro yeah how have
you been uh during uh this whole entire
weird well the world has changed the
world has changed since i've seen you
last night i know i know it's so much i
mean the last time i seen you i think i
i was put out the last album reckless
endangerment and then we were on the
press right when was that 2019 at the
end of 2019 and then we were about to go
on tour and then like release some more
[ __ ] and then the whole pandemic
happened and i was like all right let me
just like
really take some time and like level up
and like actually like i don't know it
was it was like
i felt like a time to really start
swinging for the fence on something like
all right we built a core fan base we
built like some we got some cool [ __ ]
going but now we really want to start
like
making records that make [ __ ] move you
feel me so like yeah so we just locked
ourselves in for like the whole [ __ ]
pandemic which was crazy we were up in
seattle just kind of going stir crazy
for a long time but then we came out
here and worked on it and near the end
of 2020 and now things are kind of like
dropped again you know what i'm saying
things are moving and finally doing
press [ __ ] again so it feels good bro
i've been good yeah it's crazy i saw you
say uh because i know the homies alice
was kind of like helping doing some a r
stuff and him and head always say like
uh i forget i saw you quote what they
said about making bangers or something
oh yeah yeah it was really just like nah
make slaps bro like yeah don't overthink
this don't over it's literally all about
slaps like don't [ __ ] you could wrap
your ass off all day like and this it
was the [ __ ] my friends were telling me
to my friends were literally just being
like nah we want like slaps for the car
bro like you borrowing out and [ __ ] you
like spitting your little stories and
[ __ ] not xanax bite by the way no no
there's a rabbit it's a reference
oh for xanax yeah that's all that's it's
been out i hope so i mean yeah some
[ __ ] are still down bad but i
can't even oh it's over for that good
good yeah it was over but uh yeah no we
just locked in for all 2020 and kind of
drove ourselves a little crazy in the
crib but yeah it was good it's a good
good time okay you're living in the
seattle area i am living in seattle
during uh the pandemic
and there's like this [ __ ]
zone of the city yeah chaz the chaz zone
yeah whatever the [ __ ] it's called yeah
the [ __ ] looked crazy and to me it was
like it was like
if antifa really like took over the
world that that little strip of the city
might be like no i feel you it yeah
in a way it was like it's it's a weird
like touchy subject on it because it's
like it was such a thing but it was such
a force when it happened in the city bro
and it was like definitely exaggerated
by the media you tell me it was
definitely like
like all they would show you was the
crazy [ __ ] and then like running footage
of the crazy [ __ ] like it was like this
complete like and granted there was like
two blocks where that [ __ ] was popping
off for a little bit like for a few
weeks it was definitely like was it like
hamster damn in the wire do you even
know the reference okay don't worry
about it
oh yeah i know exactly no it wasn't like
that but it was straight like i don't
know it was like half of like
people like protesting and like
patagonia with signs and nice ladies
being like yeah
and then half of like nah we're taking
this [ __ ] back like
if you're here let's let's burn some
[ __ ] down let's really like make a you
know what i'm saying let's make a so
it's like a just crazy energy i only
went up there like twice you tapped in
you tapped into the chest yeah it's not
it's not i'm like i'm frozen so it
wasn't like scary or nothing like if you
went up there bro like obviously maybe
at night [ __ ] was getting a little
hectic but like in the daytime ever you
can just walk your dog through it you
know what i'm saying that wasn't this
crap i mean there was probably people
who like had apartments in the middle of
the chat yeah no it's like i had homies
who were like uh like watching it like
going live from their balcony every
night you know what i'm saying like this
is what it looks like outside my [ __ ]
like it was insane bro like it was it
was an insane time that definitely like
seattle will never forget you know what
i'm saying you and i are pretty liberal
people i feel like based on our
conversations but i feel like
that was like when being too liberal but
being liberal gets to a little bit too
real hey man hey man i i don't even it's
a touchy subject you feel me because i'm
on i'm on some like if we want to if we
want a real change we kind of got to
start from scratch but
hey man it ain't my anymore
it ain't my place to go up and loot [ __ ]
you know i wasn't out there i wasn't out
there going crazy right now but i was
like making my voice heard and [ __ ] i
guess yeah no it was a you know i think
like
it's just so crazy to think like what
all we went through in the in a year's
time bro it was a country [ __ ] time
bro like i remember just walking around
seeing like people's faces and like the
emotions you see in people's faces were
like not we're not brand new but like i
don't know
it was wild to me bro like
it was just an emotional last time a
hectic ass time bro like we went to a
few protests down in seattle and it was
yes every time we went is an experience
like it was a whole day yeah yeah we we
went to a few out here and it was like
some of them were chill
and then one of them there was like i
saw with my own eyes
like the [ __ ] like you would see on like
instagram was like yo there's like
people dressed in all black [ __ ] [ __ ]
up no i'm not no yeah bro and it's crazy
to me how like i ain't gonna lie like we
went to one protest out in bellevue it
was like it's like the east side of
seattle and [ __ ] and it was like a
perfectly peaceful approach like no one
was doing right nothing i was up front
bro i was like very friend yeah i was up
in the
like and then i don't know where someone
throws something at a cop and then [ __ ]
just goes completely left like tear gas
like the little
grenades that they bring yellow grenades
that go off so we're running down the
street like we're like me and my manager
shelton are like huffing this gas like
trying not to puke my homies like
pouring water and milk in people's eyes
and [ __ ] like and and it was crazy to
like watch like the news report on it
when i was right there and act like it
was like a violent protest violent
protest bro it was and it wasn't like
someone threw a it was like a can or
something got thrown into a crowd of
cops and then
it just went left and then i'm watching
people report on it and they're just
like oh these violent protests are like
are they walking up to kids who are
looting like trying to get in their
faces and [ __ ] i'm like y'all aren't
reporting the story bro you're just
trying to get a sensationalized version
it's about ratings bro bro it's [ __ ]
it's and i i've always known this about
ratings i've always known it's like they
were going to show you this [ __ ] which
really this is going on but like
going there in first person and seeing
like watching
the protesters get like stories spun on
them was so ugly bro so ugly so you feel
me
yeah she got hectic in seattle but at
the same time they like sensationalized
it and made people look crazy when they
were really just making their voice
heard
no i think like that's the one thing
like uh
the news reporters in seattle are
scheisty too dude the news reporters
they put me on the news and they put me
on the news because we caught we seen
them bro like we i saw this lady doing
an interview like
lying straight up on tv like a news
reporter lying for cairo seven in
seattle she was straight up lying and i
like me and my manager sheldon like got
in her interview and we're like you're
lying that's not what happened we were
there
and they turned the camera to us and
they were like made us look like crazy
protesters right
look at this crazy look at these crazy
kids and i'm like and then so i'm
getting texts like bro you're they're
making you crazy on the news why did i
just see you on the news while i see you
on the news what i see on the news and
i'm like whoa was that like live and
come to find out it was [ __ ] live so
it was like i was on live tv and like
you're a [ __ ] liar
but it was just passion in the moment
like stop lying to the people you feel
me so yeah it was a crazy time bro let
me ask you this because like obviously
you're a young dude like and i do feel
like um
you know getting like accurate
depictions of what's really going on
newswise is hard to find nowadays right
because no matter no matter what you
watch if you watch
it used to be cnn was like
it felt like it was like you're gonna
get get you gonna get the no bias or the
msnbc no
ms see my thing is is like if you watch
msnbc you're going to get like the
hardcore like
liberal version of whatever the news is
right and then if you watch fox it's
like bad [ __ ] crazy magalan yeah and
then and then cnn used to be and but now
cnn also is like kind of full of [ __ ] so
it's like where the [ __ ] i really bro
i'd just be trying to watch twitter
videos and then try to decipher like the
energy as fast as i can bro i just be
trying to see as many like live people's
footage
twitter's the best news twitter is the
best news i'm not gonna lie like i know
i was i was i've been on facebook for
years but i've been off of it for years
but then during facebook i said i've
been off it for years yeah like i said
as soon as i started rapping bro i gave
up facebook but like i hopped back on it
during the pandemic because the lives on
there were insane bro like people were
going live through these like uprising
protests and like it was the crazy some
of the crazy [ __ ] i've ever seen bro
like you go on facebook and you'll be
like
oh damn i can't like i i you know family
members oh yeah people you went to high
school with and you'd be like these
people are crazy oh my crazy psychopaths
i'll go on facebook i like i'll randomly
go on facebook to change like some like
artists ads right on the facebook page
and then i'll like the first status i
see is like here's my baby mama back
page ad daddy let me see my kid again
the vaccine is fake the vaccinations and
i'm like oh my god or like hey i need
some cigarettes cause someone give me a
ride and i'm just like whoa bro this is
no facebook is it it's a nominee it's a
dark place
you actually know like instagram you
follow a bunch of people you you know oh
you opened up facebook you're like damn
i've known this guy for 15 years what
the [ __ ] is he talking about real life
real life bro yeah no i don't be on that
[ __ ] though and most people get
their news from memes on facebook
that's ugly bro don't say that most old
people what you are not lying brother
facebook comments are like a cesspool
it's like gross my wife's mom is she's
like an older mexican lady and she won't
get vaccinated because she's on facebook
all day god bless her she's you know one
of the hardest working ladies in the
world but she always sends my wife like
[ __ ] she finds on facebook yeah and it's
it's like it's literally on facebook and
i'm like babe tell your mom to get the
[ __ ] off the face no i'm not yeah bro
i'm not like yeah no i already know i
got mad family members like sharing [ __ ]
with me through the text and the dm's
like i'm like bro like you are not the
guy you are not the scientist who
figured this [ __ ] out bro yeah no i
already know i can't be on facebook it's
a cesspool of ignorance um
so listen man you're uh you're
give me kind of like you know
do you feel like you worked the hardest
on this album i definitely worked the
hardest on this album for sure and just
pushed ourselves way harder than before
because i don't know like like i was
telling you before we got started bro it
was very much like a we're swinging for
the fences this time and we're like we
want to make slaps like regardless of
like
i don't know we like we built a cool
thing we built like a fan base a solid
group of people who [ __ ] with me for
years who like
support us and come to shows and stream
our [ __ ] but i just i don't know i
wanted to get in front of a new audience
and like make people move for the first
time on some just fun [ __ ] on some like
just slapping a song [ __ ] you found me
so yeah we definitely worked harder on
this and we spent like a month and a
half out here in l.a meeting with
producers and meeting artists and [ __ ]
like i had never done that before prior
to that you were just like recording
seattle it was all in-house seattle [ __ ]
yeah it was all in and like if we got a
feature we send it out and like bro like
i didn't even start having rapper
friends until like reckless came out
who's your rapper friends i don't know
bro i don't i mean everyone who was on
the album or like was on the last album
i'm saying like but then we got a bunch
like for this one we started working
like i don't know [ __ ] who's the rapper
friends that are you got boogie on the
album boogie's on the album he's the
homie g-eazy's the homie who else uh
guap dad's but he's not i mean he's on
like deluxe maybe but
guap dad like rex life what that is one
of the more funniest human bro
is like a genuinely
hilarious person
did you see uh we pranked him with the
elk boys yeah bro i go live we were out
there waiting for like 15 minutes and i
started i was like hey he pranked guap
before they might be in there plotting
on us or something bro he was pissed he
was like i'm about to up pistol on you
oh he had a good night something in
there i already know i already know but
he bro it's funny too because i remember
seeing the comments for that video like
who's this guy i think he is and i'm
like oh y'all don't know guap that's
like y'all don't know yeah
that was fun we did we did another one
well we did a few but like one of them
like we did with uh
i mean at this point in time i really
don't care we did we we pranked eric
bellinger and hitmaker
they were real yes
you didn't put it out no no they
hitmaker was not [ __ ] with it
he was not and this is like right before
their album came out right and i was
like guys you have no idea they're gonna
put your the song in the video they're
gonna put the like clips to your guys
yeah
hitmaker was
so hot yes what y'all do the same thing
the same thing we're doing an interview
and then he kept coming in coming in
oh he he was not happy oh the footage
has got to be good though there's a
there's a there's jesse put out a piece
of it and blurred them out
and in the youtube comments they figured
out that at least one of the two guys
was hit making eric was cool about it
you know eric's like look man like this
is what the [ __ ] man
we're trying to do a serious interview
like and i'm like cool with eric you
know like like i'm cool with him too but
like hitmaker was so hot god damn big
walker that's good [ __ ] though it's a
good [ __ ] though and you had any other
kid from milk do it that's fire yeah
that's fire oh yeah i was definitely i
was definitely out there like [ __ ] i
really hope they don't
try to pull some [ __ ] on me because i'm
not gonna have a funny reaction i'm
gonna just get annoyed for real well you
push you i feel like you would recognize
i might have reckoned i might have been
like are you all [ __ ] with me or
something yeah no it is what it is you
know
but go out that it was interesting yeah
no but we yeah we spent out we were like
a month and a half right here so it's
just like like i said bro like it's one
being in seattle is super dope i love
being like staying in my hometown and
like going to like the bar or something
and getting free drinks and it's hella
love but then when i'm out here it's
just like [ __ ] just happens you feel me
so it's like we're making the move would
you ever move out here yeah we're making
the move in the next like few months i
think but not like permanently yeah
don't just don't get too late man you
know i know i already know you know what
it is but i'm like extremely like
aggressively a kid from seattle like you
you've known me for a few years now for
sure it's on like where's i'm so this
that i can't even try to be anything
elsie heavy yeah just you know get a
nice cool spot in the valley exactly
everyone live out in the valley out here
save some money don't go to [ __ ] west
hollywood and walk up and down melrose
with your jewelry on because everyone's
getting robbed right now everyone's
getting robbed right now melrose is
different wow it's different now even
like a few years ago
i pulled up and i was like oh this feels
different it's like it's like i
literally used to say this feels like
instagram comments in real life that's
what i used to say about melrose i'm
like this is like if the instagram
comments like came to life it's [ __ ]
melrose that's a weird place brad uh
what was it like linking with uh with uh
gerald oh man
cool i mean so basically we uh
i did the la leakers freestyle like my
first future like trip to l.a or
something like that and he he was like
the first like
artist like besides like maybe like the
one like macklemore or something that
had ever like reached out to me you know
what i'm saying like but the leakers
freestyle comes out and then that same
day he hits me up he's like yo you
[ __ ] snap this shit's hard
keep going you're going crazy and uh
and then like two years passed but i i
didn't press the issue because i'm just
like
i don't know i'm not the guy who's
i don't know i don't i don't ever want
to like be a weirdo and try to finesse a
friendship or nothing before me but like
my management and [ __ ] goes back with
him so eventually like we had a record
that made sense and we send it and he
was on and it was love bro like he was
on something like oh yeah let's make it
go up
and it was hella easy bro so really it
just came about on some like he hit me
up in the dm being like you snapped on
that freestyle i just
didn't ask for nothing just waited for a
couple years and then finally he's the
best and he's a good dude bro we shot
the video and he was on set all day
turned up when we were hitting the
costume egos together it was lit that's
my guy yeah she's like uh for being like
a
superstar that he is it's like the
coolest [ __ ] man bro the cool
rant and randomly too like he'll like he
just like he'll favor the tweet on some
like stupid [ __ ] on some random just
like he's just a genuinely good guy you
know but he's turnt up i proposed to my
wife in the middle of his set in uh some
festival i brought it out yeah i brought
her out yeah jeez like one of my closest
friends in the industry yeah
hell yeah now he's a good dude bro i was
that's why i was like oh they did a song
together i wonder what that studio
session was like oh tonight see i wish i
was trying to make it happen in person
but now we made that have you partied
with g8 can you hang because it gets
serious i mean i it's like i don't be
i'll be off the the real drugs or
nothing but yeah i feel like i can def i
was definitely drinking and [ __ ] you
went to vegas with them and did the
resorts world right yeah so yeah we did
uh what's it called we were out in vegas
for the first time and he got us like a
section with bottles you know he's a
professional at partying like oh no he's
he's a he's a yeah like i'll be like
i'll be with him like like when he was
doing dre's and vegas obviously like i
just can't [ __ ] hang these guys do
the [ __ ] normal club then they go do
the after hours walk outside the club is
[ __ ] 100 degrees and the sun is out
bro nah they're they're different
they're on like literally he pulled up
to the shoot i think like hours after he
had just got back from doing uh
not oh reno he was just in reno so he
hops out the car in like his pajamas and
he's like
his whole team was like i don't know how
he's awake right now he's been up for
dead
i know how he yeah
he's lit though he lit that's my boy
he's good for it and he's just dropping
album and [ __ ] too like yeah no album
comes out september 24th boom these
things happen too you feel me but yeah
no he's so he he's on some genuine [ __ ]
like he was giving me mad advice on
shoot two because he goes back with
benner my manager and he was just like i
don't know you could tell like he pulled
up and he was like he like cared about
it you found me no side note side note
benner
might be the coolest name ever for real
benner the banner that's hard i guess so
i never gave him the credit for that one
but yeah i need a bad name yeah what's
your name my name is benner bro
i banner over you they go they go
they go you're hella dumb
better over
god damn now everywhere we go they'd be
like bennett and he's like nah benner
and they're like whoa okay bet yeah it's
kind of hard
uh yeah good dude bro for real
so uh
boulevard boy
yes you have a tattooed on your hands i
did i tatted it on my hands was this
prior to you making this your album uh
yeah no it was it was prior just because
boulevard boys is the um i grew up on
ambon boulevard and then me and my
friends llc like our business is below
our boys
what's the llc and what do you guys what
kind of business you guys in besides the
music it's just that yeah it's just
music
i don't know if you got a pizza place or
something hey you're telling us about a
pizza restaurant by your house no i'm
really trying to like i grew up in uh
like right next to a pizza place i
remember when i started working there
when i was like 16 that's how i bought a
microphone and [ __ ] on the laptop but uh
i just did a pizza there for the album
just had my own pizza worked behind the
counter and everything it was lit and i
was talking to them i was like let's
open up a second one let's do it let's
do it let's do it so you never know it's
funny you say that too because like i
genuinely want to like invest in that
[ __ ] if you could open any type of
restaurant would it be like what would
it be outside of a pizza place because
obviously you want to do this yeah the
pizza is only i just worked there and i
feel like i know what other food you're
most passionate about
man it's not american food and it would
feel greasy i don't know i my friend
does a native american and soul food
combined and because i'm navajo so like
like from the resident everything so
like it would be tight for me to have
like a fusion native restaurant kind of
you feel me because my homies like half
black half native and you feel me so
he's he's like i'm like [ __ ] we could
like so it's like fry bread so it's like
yeah it's like classic soul dishes but
like with native american twists so like
fried bread or like stews and just
randomly yo that that fry bread is a
movie bro i know i'm telling you bro
telling you like now you had like fried
bread tacos like navajo tacos no yeah
yeah i mean i'm from arizona there's a
bunch oh yeah you're from arizona bruh
so you know you were around
but that's the thing bro you you meet
people who aren't from
like the southwest and they just look at
natives like they're mexican or
something they don't even know they're
around natives but people from arizona
you'd be like oh no yeah like my high
school was like uh the reds started like
a half a mile from my high school so
all the homies all went you know like my
friend doug is native he's navajo yeah
yeah i'm my family from fort defiance
like window rock up in
i forgot like a couple years ago i
posted a picture of my boy doug and he's
like yo man he's putting on for us bro
you damn right
oh yeah i remember that yeah yeah man
yeah man the natives show us love
because bro it's not no native rappers
out here really yeah i think the only
other native uh rapper was uh i think it
was some dude signed us like [ __ ]
psychopathic records or some [ __ ] back
in the day i think it was some guy named
abk and i i think you put me onto a
wrench i know way too much about that
world nah there's some there's some kids
now there's a kid from arizona called
res coast grips oh red coast grizz is my
boy fire bro [ __ ] [ __ ] fire
buckling that tribe called red like
snotty knows redskins shout out to rest
coast grizz man bro i'm really [ __ ]
with him he's fire he's he's he can do
everything he can bro he's like a na
like he really looks like one of my
cousins or something like for sure i
showed it to my dad and my dad flipped
he looks like somebody who laid me out
in a like a mosh pit
at some point in time when i was like in
high school at a show well he literally
looks like my cousin so like i showed it
to my pop so my pastor's like whoa that
he's fire yeah he's super fire bro i
mean yeah it's
it's uh it's weird being a native rapper
out here you feel me but it's cool it's
tight people [ __ ] with us yeah it's it's
uh you know
coming up like around a bunch of the
native homies like yeah
a lot it was like
a lot of the native dudes were always
into like technine
and yeah icp i was really going to say
icp yeah
like the strange music wave and [ __ ]
yeah yeah so like yeah like and then i
would always like or it would be like
rock [ __ ] like this yes like white
stripes or something yeah yeah why go to
like some hardcore like rock shows
anytime like be some giant native would
jump in the [ __ ] mosh pit it
would just be over for everybody
throwing native bows yeah
yeah the native boasts the native votes
nah yeah it's
it's interesting bro i'm not gonna lie
like we'll we'll go play shows
in arizona and it's like a guy like a
majority native crowd sometimes and then
we'll get out and like i'll be on stage
i'm like damn i feel like these kids
aren't hella turned up like i feel like
these and then i'll get off and like
they're losing their minds you feel me
so it's just weird like i don't know
like
watching native people react to native
rappers is almost a new thing as well as
being a native rapper so it's just i
don't know it's weird bro but it's i
love it bro you're half native half what
half native have white i mean like
german what kind of german and irish oh
i'm german and irish i think yeah my mom
doesn't my mom's always like why don't
you like talk about that i'm like you
don't get here i'm like you don't know
first off no one cares and you don't
care yeah you don't care you know we
never don't know german yeah like when's
the last time you made a [ __ ] what's
some german like what's the last time
you made sauerkraut
schnitzel yeah yeah what you feel me
like never but yeah no it's so you feel
me white lady but yeah that's how my
wife's always like why don't you ever
like rep the i'm like i just grew up in
a white household you feel me this is
just white it's just generic it's like
my parents didn't [ __ ] they weren't
like yo here's a what is the [ __ ] the
the [ __ ] the irish people eat the
[ __ ] shepherd's pie or whatever yeah
nobody ate nobody made that we were just
white people my dad made enchiladas one
night and then next night salisbury
steak
bro like my parents were my parents were
chefs in seattle too so like they just
i've been on different types of food my
whole life so i was like literally like
as a kid eating in jira and like food
and [ __ ] i was like you're eating food
as a kid as a baby bro like bro i i'm a
big boy because i'm sorry my parents
were chefs and like they put me on to
everything my parents just made the
basic generic [ __ ] here's roast here's
meatloaf no no my words went crazy we
ordered pizza and i didn't feel you i
feel you i feel you now my parents were
chefs at like a hotel that's how that's
how they met so the meals i didn't have
fun so i was like 25 years old are you
serious yeah wow i mean seattle has
hella like asian immigrants like hello
vietnamese
so it's like we've had fun in like as
long as chicken noodle soup
yo it's crazy because seattle is also
like loki like a baby like a
silicon valley now
yes i mean i guess yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] it up but it it yes that's right
i went to [ __ ] seattle and there was
like the only the first time i ever saw
one of those amazon stores where there's
nobody in it oh yeah you can just walk
in and just scan yourself what is going
on here bro it's very different now like
i'll be walking the block and you'll see
one of the robots just like going like
just delivering something for amazon
it's insane bro it's yeah it's different
it's super different but yeah it is what
it is hey what up man we got to
interrupt the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at odd socks
now when i be riding for odd socks so
hard man it's because i really love the
product they got the most comfortable
socks in the [ __ ] world i got a pair
of odd socks basics on right now go get
those they got the socks wwe joints you
know i'm saying shout out to the
undertaker pepsi [ __ ] really
whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxoficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksoficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview so
obviously you worked a lot during the
pandemic but you know i'm sure you
probably did you binge watch any tv did
you get into any gaming what were you
doing like at the crib like what was
your man i don't know we watched i've
watched i feel like i've watched every
horror film probably ever what's your
favorite
my favorite horror movie give me like
three of them give me three horror
movies i really like um
i ain't gonna lie i really felt with
this movie called creep
you ever seen creep it's about this guy
who like puts out a craigslist ad
and he like tries to get someone to come
film his life it's like an independent
move it's so good bro you gotta watch
creep i really like hush
these are i'm newer one because we can
go classic bro cause like clap i haven't
seen hush so kush is fire it's felt like
a deaf woman who has to like defend
herself from an intruder i'm going new
you feel me because classic ones i don't
know i don't i hate debating classic
movies with people bro do you like
master debating classic movies yeah for
sure yeah for sure uh i don't know
what's another one i'll go classic for
the last one you feel me but like i love
the i love the first saw the first song
is great first saw is so good first like
two or three were cool and then this
[ __ ] just kind of got a little the first
side was like revolutionary but yeah for
sure you feel me like i love like
watching a horror film and you're like
oh [ __ ] this was the base for a bunch of
other horror films you know what i'm
saying like a whole lot of that kind of
[ __ ] like like i know what she did last
summer is corny but like but it was a
bro classic it revolutionized [ __ ]
paranormal activity classic
revolutionization you know what i'm
saying so it's like people hate like
appreciating new horror films which is
annoying do you ever watch human
centipede yeah that's like a [ __ ] that's
like a middle school for fun
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is well i watched the first
one and it was it was disturbing bro
it's super no but the second one is oh
i had to turn it off yeah not no they
like [ __ ] smash a baby's head under
like a brake pedal in a car i'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on here that [ __ ]
is literally just like a
what's it what's the word for i don't
know but they're just trying they're
just trying to like yeah weird you out
shock you make you [ __ ] like
uncomfortable in this [ __ ] i can't rock
it's like the six nine of like horror
movies god damn
there's one two i think people call it
like a serbian film or some [ __ ] that i
hear about like bruh that [ __ ] is nasty
to me bro yeah
but like i was saying the classic horror
films we ran up and it's all kinds of
movies bro like and i feel like i
appreciated music more too like just
sitting in the crib like i feel like for
a long time i felt like a rapper who put
words over beats and now i feel like
just
working on music and like trying to
learn chords on the piano and just like
trying to understand melody more i feel
way more like a musician now than i ever
have that's dope you feel me now i'm
like i like that starting to like learn
your i mean at the end of the day
you everyone gets better bro everyone
understands music more because like you
said you could anybody like like not
anybody can rap like you but anybody can
record lyrics over a beat exactly but
there's so much more musically you know
that you got to get to really you know
the exact same thing exactly and i just
feel like
i needed to sit down for a while to
fully understand like and just
appreciate music like i wasn't putting
on music the way i do now like before
i'd be like i'm in music all day bro i'm
sick of it i'm gonna put on a podcast or
something i don't wanna hear music but
now i wake up like excited to like
listen to what do you listen like what
do you listen to like
like set it over yeah i mean just like
because i i feel like sometimes there's
like a fine line between i can't even
lie and say that it was someone else's
music that made me like fall in love
with it it was really just like
appreciating my own music i think we
made like dead prezis and crossfaded
like those are like some of the first
songs we made for the album so it was
like or like maybe not crossfit but
anyways like some of like the singles
were the first songs we made for the
album so it was like oh [ __ ] these are
way better than anything i ever done
how can i keep making these ones again
in the process of like just making a
million songs is what made me fall in
love with music you know what i've been
doing lately is like when i'm like
trying to get some [ __ ] done i'm trying
to relax
i'll throw on some like lo-fi hip-hop
instrumentals that's what you've been on
there's okay there's like this like the
lo-fi chill beats to study yeah yeah
yeah there's like there's like a loop on
youtube in the comment section it's like
bart simpson just going like this for
like 10 hours in like a coffee shop or
something bro like the what's crazy is
the low five beats to and like chill to
study playlist on youtube go read the
comments it's in it because it's a
24-hour video yeah so it's like
those comments bro they have people are
having whole debates on like under lo-fi
like religious debate master debates yes
master debates in the lo-fi like hop
beats they're just going back and forth
it's like a reddit forum it's literally
like a reddit forum or like a live
tweeting thread like bro it's insane bro
it's yeah it's crazy okay uh what's
better donda or certified loverboy
i think
i like i prefer certified lover boy more
but
there aren't there i think this the
songs that i love on donda i love more
than the songs i love on
so if i live boy if that makes sense
like that makes sense
i love pure souls i love come to life
okay okay part two jail part two like i
love those [ __ ] songs more than i
think i like way too sexy even though
i'm playing way too sexy like five times
a day yeah i say like if you take like
the top like six or seven records off of
donda's it's [ __ ] no it's amazing yeah
like i ain't gonna lie i love hurricane
i love [ __ ] that off the grid is
crazy yeah bro but then you play
certified little boys at the bottom and
you're like bro it's undeniable it's
it's london hell yeah what are you
kidding me yeah that [ __ ] slap bro and
i'm not even like i'm not even the
biggest drake fan like my homies are
like the drake fans i'm the one that's
so you're saying front to back
it's undeniable certified love reporter
yeah yeah front to back for sure bro
it's fire what do you mean you don't
agree with that i just think it is the
most
generic
uh on i just feel like it was the most
uninspired attempt at an album i've
heard in a long time you thought you
played it safe or something i mean he
always plays the safe but that's the
thing bro bro i said i saw a world no
you're playing safe when you're number
one i saw rory say this uh on his
podcast with maul he said that uh
somebody he knew said that it felt like
drake
was pair like making a parody of himself
oh yeah
yeah and i was like yeah i saw someone
be like uh what was the first uh mixtape
that he put out october's very own
uh what was the what was it it wasn't so
far gone it was before that it was um
yeah
was it come uh what the [ __ ] was the
name of that tape what's the message i
don't know the did you know yeah come
back season
yeah i heard i heard like the homie zeni
say it was like basically just
repurposed comeback season and i was
like damn that's a crazy take but no i
don't know bro to me there's no playing
it safe when you're that big let me ask
you something do you like mcdonald's
yeah of course you used to not like
mcdonald's but now i became a touring
rapper and then you don't learn to love
so mcdonald's is the biggest restaurant
in the world right for show for sure and
in order for it to be the biggest
restaurant in the world it literally has
to be good now it might not be good like
yeah like mcdonald's is fire yeah that's
what i'm saying that's not like but hot
fresh mcdonald's is the [ __ ] it's the
best it's a better meal than like
ruth chris i agree you feel me i love
mcdonald's
bro i used to be a big hater and then i
started touring and i'm like no
mcdonald's
you put the fries on your burger isaiah
rashad put me on he told me he or he i
seen an interview he was like yo bro
like you
you show up to mcdonald's and you say
hey do you have the time to make this
fresh like i'll wait i'll wait and if
they got the time to make everything
fresh smacks so crazy so
drake you saying drake's like mcdonald's
he's the mcdonald's of hip-hop he's the
biggest and he is good as [ __ ] and at
times he's fresh you see this he's fresh
mcdonald's drake is mcdonald's he's a
different kind of mcdonald's because
he's like serving filet mignon so maybe
he's like mcdonald's in like singapore
that's what i'm saying bro like he's got
it if he's mcdonald's he's got to be
like an like a exquisite mcdonald's so
he's mcdonald's and this album to me was
just another big mac he knew i look this
this works it's gonna sell let me just
throw another big mac out there where in
i want i want him to like
take some risks creatively
like
i feel like we want that and we don't
want that no i do i mean i'm just like
bro you want that because you're a music
person
the everyday listener doesn't want that
so
i don't know if that's true because you
got someone like tyler the creator or
you got someone like kendrick lamar who
every time kendrick drops he is pushing
the boundaries of being creative so my
thing with drake is yes he is the
mcdonald's of hip-hop which is okay
because i love mcdonald's i love drake
with that being said this album to me
just solidified that i was like oh this
fool's just mailing it in i feel you but
how do you define what's better if like
like if you go out for if you go out for
the evening mcdonald's will make sense
sometime that night
yeah if you go out for the evening
whatever you would compare donna to
might not make sense that night for sure
mcdonald's always makes how can you
quantify what's no mcdonald's always
makes sense you feel me it's always
convenient it's always there but it's
not going to win a james beard award
i guess so i guess so bro i guess so two
different goals man like and the thing
is is i want drake to put an album out
that could win album of the year at the
grammys not hip-hop album of the year
album of the year at the grammys cause
he's that big of an artist nah i feel
you i feel you it's a it's a it's a fair
thing to ask i just as a rapper it's
hard for me to even like i'm just like
brother the run is like unprecedented
no one has ever done what drake's doing
period he's the biggest ever he's got
more hits than anyone ever and his run
is longer than anyone's run at the top
has ever been these are all undeniable
longer than jay-z
yeah at the top so you're saying drake's
more legendary than jay-z no no no no no
oval rap circles run trick and i'll take
jay's catalog over drake's all day but
but you got to understand jay-z's first
number one record on billboard didn't
come to 0-9 it was uh empire state of
minor blueprint 3. so the first time jay
ever got a number one song was 2009. it
was empire state of mind are you kidding
me bro oh my god but think about how
many number one records drake has gotten
since 2000 and [ __ ] i mean drake's
been the guy for for longer than anyone
and yeah no that's insane i didn't know
hove didn't go [ __ ] that's insane i
don't know that's wild to me wow yeah so
i think drake is that guy i just i know
i had an argument like me me and freddie
gibbs ran into drake at at some place
out here and uh we literally argued for
an hour about his music
to with him
yes i had to tell him because my boy
eric larocque was with me fred was with
me and i'm i keep the same energy
and you could kind of tell i don't know
if he saw some interviews or something
but you could tell i was like hey look
man i just got to keep the same energy
bro like i always say like you're super
dope but i just want more from you you
told him that straight up straight to
his freddy gibbs as my witness
and then he started breaking he started
breaking down like well you know where
i'm from i that's what i told him i said
you don't have a a consensus
hip-hop classic now that doesn't mean
you looked drake in the face and said
you don't have a consensus hip-hop
classic i'll call freddie gibbs right
now and he'll tell you i said that to
his face oh my god you're crazy so i
mean so then he starts like this dude so
passionate and i respected it because
i'm like who the [ __ ] am i to be arguing
with drake at a bar at the harriet you
know what i'm saying
yeah for sure he's like
he's like
pretty much just like you know where i'm
from the music's different and what i
what i do you would never a hip-hop guy
like you would never consider and i'm
like no i think take care is a classic
to me
but you don't got a doggy style or get
rich or die trying where nobody can say
[ __ ] you don't think nothing was the
same he wasn't wrapping his ass off
that's my favorite album of his yeah i
mean yeah cause he would you that you
the hip-hop guy
that's my favorite album i already know
exactly
and i consider that to be like a
borderline classic but but the thing is
is like there's these albums that we
look at in hip hop
that nobody can say [ __ ] to you if you
call it a classic right illmatic doggy
style good kid mad city 36 chambers
right
my beautiful dark twisted fantasy all
these albums if you call them a classic
there's nobody who has a serious opinion
about hip-hop will question you
it's it's split like if i say take care
as a classic i know 50 dudes that are
that might be like it was good it's not
a clown you know what i'm saying but
give it like
15 years though
maybe but yeah but like good kid mad
city my beautiful turtles and fantasy
these these these albums are classics
take care as a classic
i think it is i think but i think that
in the within the hip hop community i
don't think it's a consensus classic i
don't think everyone's like really i
don't think so damn i get [ __ ] and i
love take care and i love drake i was
just born in 96 so drake is just like
damn you were born in 96.
so like drake has been a thing since i
was like nine since you were listening
to music yeah no i ca yeah literally i
remember drake getting signed you know
what i'm saying like yeah
yeah
it's insane i'm old as dirt bro no [ __ ]
i was born i was born in 87 you're born
87 yeah that's not see you're lit though
because you can say you were born in the
80s but you're not old yet for real
isaiah rashad gave me the most
backhanded compliment what do you say
we're talking about uh
i forget but we're arguing about some
[ __ ] and i was like uh
i was like well i'm not even that old
bro no what did he say
he's like you're a old head or some [ __ ]
and i'm like bro you're aren't you 30.
he's like yeah i'm like bro i'm 34
relaxed he's like you're only 34
and he was like at first i thought you
were old head who looked young that's
crazy
he's like now you're just a young head
that looks old i said what does that
mean that's crazy no i would have i
would have assumed mid 30s that's crazy
damn i didn't know isaiah was 30 though
yeah
i mean [ __ ] be old man
i just made it off with the odds right
after that thanks but i'm about to be 25
this month though because i feel like
i'm getting there uh
who is like your like uh if you had to
like you know
let's say this what are your like top
three or four albums all the time
like all genre
anything
so the three albums three i'll say the
albums that shaped me for real were like
the first one was like the first piece
of music i ever fell in love with and
that was like american idiot by green
day i think that [ __ ] came out like when
i was like eight years old or something
like that that was a moment yeah that
like changed i was like that's when i
like really fell in love with music
there was like a whole play revolved
around that album yeah but still it's
like on broadway still and everything
bro but like so american idiot by green
day
college dropout i found that around the
same time yeah i was and those were like
i had like two albums on my my like
three gig mp3 player you know what i'm
saying so i like green day and kanye
were like what i was running like those
two albums and then uh
the curtain call which is just like the
eminem compilation was like yeah it was
the greatest hits that was in my dad's
car all the time so those three plus
like
um the score by the fujis
those four albums were like when i think
about my childhood that's what was being
played who who was listening to the
score around you my dad like my dad like
put me on to all that okay yeah my dad
my sister where our big music has
he said the curtain call i mean that was
greatest hits yeah no that's not but
that's how you know i'm a kid you feel
me like i didn't know about the slim
shady lp until i had had you shoot you
feel me so like yeah but my dad was a
big like public enemy fan too but those
four albums were like the ones that i
like would steal and be like these are
my albums
how big of a deal is it like being a kid
and then the the macklemore album comes
out in 2012 and he had always been
independently successful in like a name
like in the underground you know but
things really changed uh when that album
came out i mean it changed everything
for the whole city and like nothing will
be the same after that and i also feel
like we got to a point where like we
stopped respecting macklemore for some
reason when he's like legitimately like
the nicest dude ever has the best morals
is probably one of the most transparent
artists of
time music thank you brother he was he
was
all
was dealt uh a shitty like internet hand
in the sense of like he had a crazy
haircut beat kendrick for the grammy you
know i really think that's all it was it
was it was literally just him beating
kendrick for the grammy
everyone's allowed to be corny bro or
everyone's allowed to be seen as corny
to everyone like you're like but that's
you can't knock someone for that but
when they take an award that you felt
like should have went to the one of the
greatest hip-hop albums of all time how
are you not going to become like an
enemy in people's but that didn't stop
bro like i ain't gonna lie like after
that whole [ __ ] happened he took me on
tour and like he like helped put me on
you know what i'm saying and like he's
the best he's and bro like he
has he he consistently does [ __ ] for the
city that he doesn't even like talk
about and yeah it's one of them things
where it's like people always got an
opinion and i get it because i and but i
ain't gonna lie it's been very telling
like to like
i watch people who like don't [ __ ] with
him but [ __ ] with me but don't [ __ ] with
him for the same reasons that like they
[ __ ] like i'm just you feel me i'll just
do something it's just she just gets a
bad rep for no reason i'll be walking
around seattle and like the people i'm
around will say something about mac and
i'm like okay okay let me get these hits
off y'all ain't gonna [ __ ] with me in
like two years yeah you feel me because
i just be knowing bro it's like
[ __ ] always have [ __ ] to say
but it is what it is bro like everyone's
allowed to have an opinion and [ __ ] but
like
i just think like macklemore for
whatever reason like
you know i really think it was the
kendrick moment
but i think like we just forget like how
good the music was
he hasn't put out music in a couple
years but i mean it still is very good
so i don't want to bro like he and he's
like an independent anomaly like thrift
shop you know diamond song and it's an
independent an independent diamond song
like people don't have a different kind
of bread like women
rich rich him and ryan lewis are so
stupidly you know i'm saying bro like
and they brought so much to the game
when it comes to just their visuals
there will never be another artist like
chance or like macklemore or like
because these are independent anomalies
and i'm gonna be honest bro like when
people say like independent and they're
really not independent mclemore wasn't
that and the reason and some people
don't know bro they don't know he
literally just hired of labels radio
staff to work his records like he wasn't
signed because he had warner brother
working all his [ __ ] to radio but he
wasn't signed a warner brother he
literally just hired yeah i already know
bro and he's just been solid from jump
from me bro like any time that he's like
what you got going on i'm like oh i'm
talking about this like send me the
contract or something he's the best when
you got it bro let me see it you found
me like you know what i mean and he does
that for people i think he also broke
down so many walls for like you know
just transparency and rap like you know
the fact like he talked about his drug
addiction so openly and yeah and it'd be
pissing me off too because i feel like
he came from like this hip-hop
background like he was a boy he was on
some backpacks he was on some backpack
[ __ ] but then when he blew up all the
backpack fans were like
you're not this anymore it's like bro
like really listen because there are
those songs you just don't like it
because it's famous now that [ __ ] that
should be getting to me bro that [ __ ]
happens every time white backpack has
anytime someone it's all love i'm a
white backpack head i'm just saying yeah
i know those white backpack fans are
weirdos or weird bro but this i we're
we're both those guys so we can't hate
on them you know quite a bit yeah
what percentage of your fan base are
juggalos
a few i ain't gonna lie
because i'm just a chubby weird looking
dude so we attract like chubby
weird-looking dudes to the shows you
feel me like people pull up and they're
like hey bro like the house
tattooed on their cats you can feel me
they might be wearing some crazy [ __ ]
like like a lot of like uh
the chained wallets or something you
know
especially when you're in arizona you
see that you see how all that [ __ ] you
feel me all how the native kids out
there we dread like the rocker kids a
lot of kids love that exactly would you
ever would you ever take the bag to do
the gathering of the juggalos
man if i was the artist who i felt like
that would be recepted well yeah hell
yeah i would do it bro i would i want to
go to the gathering regardless but even
if i'm i want to go just to like
experience it hi bro you kidding me the
skate park i grew up at like it was ran
basically it was the skaters versus the
juggalos every day it was like it would
be like 30 of us skaters every day and
then like the juggalos kind of like
lived at the park you feel me so like
they were [ __ ] dude so anytime the
cops pulled up the juggalos will blame
us we blame the juggalos you feel me
it's the juggalos
they're clearly on meth literally bro
yeah no we had we we were getting big
brawls with the juggalos and [ __ ] but at
the end like once you grow up you
realize hey man i see if he's legendary
bro i i i've no no no icp i hated on it
my whole childhood because i didn't [ __ ]
with juggalos you feel me my whole life
like my cousin would come over he'd have
the icp shirt on back bro you're corny
for that like take that [ __ ] off no for
sure
and then i became a musician and i'm
like oh my god well the music's terrible
but what [ __ ] with that one like the
homies
that [ __ ] that that's a slapper
my cousin was into an album called the
great malinka when i was a kid and it
was like all right because it was like
funny because they were like doing like
weird like horror course [ __ ] yeah but
what i'll say about them is like they
really laid the blueprint for so much of
the independent [ __ ] so much of the
merch [ __ ] going on right now the [ __ ]
i'd be sitting in all these festivals
that go online yeah they they laid like
everyone having a festival icp had their
festival first you feel me like icp ran
up the merch before everybody though
they got to be so stupid we were talking
about that the other day we were like
literally it might have been two days
ago i was like
how much you think icp's worth and they
were like bro they were nationally
recognized as a gang by the fed like by
the fbi they're they're breaded you know
they got bread dude they're ready shout
out icp i don't listen to it but that's
their legends yeah no they're legends
for sure i hope i get to you know i i
think i met them
and they bro the fact that their fans
ride for that [ __ ] so hard is so crazy
to me like the fan base they've built i
don't [ __ ] get it like you know what
i feel like it started to slow down a
bit because because those fans are like
40 now with kids for sure and you and
you'll see somebody i remember i saw
somebody at the park like a couple of
years ago that looked like he just got
off from a corporate ass job playing
with his kids the hatchet
and he had the hatchet tattoo on his
calf yep i was like
oh
yeah man i remember like be like being
at school and a ta or something never it
would never be a teacher but like
someone who employee of the school would
like slide his sleeves up to like help
you with the problem and like it's a
hatchet on his arm and you're like this
is like you're a juggalo you grew up
like a white collar guy you know what
i'm saying like [ __ ] it's that in the
cod mouth kings dudes
oh yeah they go wow yeah yeah that was
like a whole like nice little underbelly
of my high school shout out to the cod
mouth kings i went to all those shows
icp would [ __ ] launch [ __ ] fago
[ __ ] two leaders into the crowd no i
remember it bro going up to skate park
they do fago showers and [ __ ] like they
have like i swear to god bro they get
like they get like the 24 pack and they
dump it on my bro in the park in the
park bro and they'd film it with their
cell phones and be like they got
initiated into this bro i don't know
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i am not lying i i i run deep with the
juggalos so in seattle
skaters versus skaters versus juggalos i
can't take the parking it was just out
this iberian skatepark i grew up okay so
near seattle yeah skaters versus
juggalos at the park you would witness
juggalos being initiated into the
juggalo circle with a fago shower with
faygo showers bro and yeah and they
would film it and then like
they might they might even like jump in
bro it would the juggalos like the
skatepark would grab out we're on some
crazy [ __ ] for sure and they come smoke
they like go on the ground where they
smoke little cigarettes like cigarette
butts and [ __ ] oh yeah the girls be
coming up trucking for like so low and
we were like 13 year olds and we're like
no we're not gonna buy vagina we're like
13. dude that's the one thing like it
was insane bro i would always like you
know i'm real close with tech nine so
i've probably been to 50 tech nine shows
like man the tech nine groupies got to
be the ugliest groupies you're greasy as
[ __ ] you're so easy christ i can't
imagine i can't imagine what the
juggalettes look like out here i mean
shout out strange music man and no i
love travis and the women who love
but it's like you know ritz is a right
white rapper he's one of my best friends
right i love ritz but i'm [ __ ] jesus
christ the ritz concert the [ __ ] that
show up these uh you're not here they're
so great they look like my honor they
look like my aunt wendy
you're [ __ ] up bro oh my god these
women are out here just trying to show
up and support and they're like look i
got a ritz tattoo on my calf and you're
like
oh you're greasy you're crazy
yeah
i bet you do
all right uh you have someone tattoo
your face yet yeah i'm not i'm not once
again we've been we've got a bunch of
lyrics [ __ ] for like years now but my
first portrait was on like this kid's
leg he showed up to our show like last
month was he like a normal normal dude
what yeah like the cool and he's you
know he's been rocking with us for years
like he pulled up and he was like you
know i'm at mikey stays baked and i'm
like oh yeah i've known this at nino
when someone pulls yeah like you've been
[ __ ] with me for a long time but bro
i'm not gonna lie to you it was one of
the biggest trips in my whole life look
at this [ __ ] zoom in on his [ __ ]
zoom in like it's a full portrait on the
back of his leg that [ __ ] tripped me out
bro shout out to mikey stays baked mikey
stays back you feel me yeah no that's
keeping those camel shorts of live bro
puts you in perspective because i'll
wake up and i'll just be depressed and
i'm like well [ __ ] son
mikey's got my face on his leg yeah i
gotta go hard for mikey i can't give up
yeah you feel me otherwise he's gonna
look crazy oh my mama bro i'll be
keeping me i gotta i can't say nothing
crazy you got to be working hard can't
you gonna be a good person
do you ever like worry
about like
being too transparent or honest like
because it's so easy to get canceled now
no i don't
i don't worry about getting canceled
just because like bro like i grew up
doing like uh
like uh what's it called beating up
jugglers
but like when i got into high school i
did like spoken word poetry and [ __ ] so
they put us through like like social
justice workshops and [ __ ] so like the
empathy been running db for me it's like
no it's not even about that it's not
gonna get nervous on some like
i like i'm just like a contrarian ass
person and just like i feel like i'm too
opinionated so like i'll be i'll get on
twitter one day and be like damn like
coleslaw is [ __ ] ass anyone who eats
coleslaw is an idiot for real and then
people were like damn bro i just got
your [ __ ] tatted and i love coleslaw bro
and i feel like i just let them down or
some [ __ ] you feel me i don't worry
about getting canceled i feel like just
like becoming someone that people are
like oh that guy's a dick you listen to
a lot of what podcast you listen to
[ __ ] um i don't know i listened to rory
and maul's podcast i [ __ ] with rory um
i [ __ ] with bad friends podcasts the
andrew santino and bobby lee won
i like the million dollars with the game
one oh i love it obviously i love
drinking champs you feel me drink chance
is great nah yeah
andrew's and bobby lee [ __ ] is hilarious
bro i think they're like
that's my favorite podcast brother
andrew santino's about to be a star i
feel like oh for sure especially that
dave money coming in yeah
no i'm genuinely who's your favorite
like obviously if you understand the
comedians
what's it called my my parents and my
like dad specifically are like stand-up
nerds you feel me so like well every
time we're out in new york and la we
always try to catch a stand-up show but
like comedy story for a long time i
really [ __ ] with angie yeah comedy store
but uh andrew santino i've looked at him
for a long time i really like gavin matz
this guy named jack knight he's from
mountain seattle who else but then i
also like like obviously like john
mulaney and like pete holmes mm-hmm you
feel me and yeah bro all over the place
we'd be at comedy events like i go to
comedy shows oftentimes i love it bro
yeah that was the hardest part about
everything shut down the [ __ ] out the
art form bro you just pull it to the
comedies there's nothing like like
taking your girl to the comedy story
eating some [ __ ] shitty food getting
some drinks and just watching like 20
comics you feel me and you never know
who's gonna pull up like for sure like
literally we went to the comedy store
last time i was out here like a year ago
and it was like
it was it was it was like a not even a
theme night it was like some random
people you've never heard of but then
andrew santino did a set marc maron did
a set
like all these random like people you
bet oh i've seen them in a netflix show
like we're just popping out that's and
being in a comedy city is such a you
feel me like yeah i went i've been out
been a few times where like martin
lawrence hopped on i mean yeah that's
different
than like uh joe rogan wasn't supposed
to be on but he came on and did some
[ __ ] and then
you know who i think is hilarious
it's [ __ ] tim dillon oh i know yeah
yeah he's funny yeah i [ __ ] with him i
like tim dillon because
i think he breaks everyone's brains
because he's like a a gay dude yeah
but he also like just doesn't give a
[ __ ]
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
that pulls out a maniac um boulevard boy
is out obviously crazy features on it
you got um
uh jeezy on there boogie on there
juicy j is on there you feel me yeah
chat to juicy j man yeah no that's like
my favorite song in the world you feel
me like getting the juicy vocals back
and hearing my hook come after his
[ __ ] verse was like a moment um
are you already working on new music uh
yeah where i wear where's it i only came
out like a month ago so we're now back
in on some like we've been sitting
around for like three weeks so we have
to kind of like if everybody's in the
studio
yeah you feel me if you're not in the
studio every day as a rapper you almost
feel like you're bullshitting what about
touring like obviously it's it's a lot
of literally supposed to go on tour
supposed to be on tour right now but it
got cancelled because this whole delta
[ __ ] but i'm about to announce like
tomorrow i think like we're doing new
york la and then doing a whole west
coast run yeah i've been seeing like
some artists have just been cancelling
their tours because yeah they don't want
to put their fans through the thing but
i'm like yo this might be kind of the
new normal so you guys should just
[ __ ] get over it and i mean it
definitely is the new normal for sure
like this shit's not going away like
there's gonna be venues where you have
to be vaccinated to get in there's gonna
be venues where they want you to have a
test or pull up and take your oh my mama
bro yeah it's to be like that for a long
[ __ ] time yeah
yeah go support the album yeah go
support the album come see me in new
york la and we're doing a bunch of shows
on the west coast soon so yeah man there
it is uh there's merch i'm sure you got
a website oh yeah below
ambonboulevard.com or boulevardboy.com
did you say n-bomb and bomb oh okay the
head does that same [ __ ] man jesus
christ you're hella funny ambon
boulevard.com and the boulevardboy.com
yeah and everything you can find
a question in which if you answer it no
matter what the answer is it's racist
shout out that's my bro yeah yeah head's
a wild boy man head will be like yo kev
there i won't even
he he knows what he does this is the
fact no everyone knows what he is
west coast there it is west coast